öffnung spektive für die bürger bund und
länder suchen nach möglichkeiten die
korona maßnahmen zu lockern
baustelle wohnungsbau
die bundesregierung sieht ihre
förderziele fast erreicht scharfe kritik
kommt dagegen von investoren und
mieterschutz und zurück in die wildnis
auf borneo finden orang utans wieder
neuen alten lebensraum die nachrichten
des tages heute mit petra gerster guten
abend herzlich willkommen bei den 19 uhr
nachrichten am dienstag mit sport
natürlich und den hat norbert lehmann
dabei ein stück von mir eine öffnungs
strategie muss her das ist das neue
mantra in sachen corona spätestens
nächste woche mittwoch soll es konkrete
aussichten auf weitere lockerungen geben
dann nämlich wenn sich die kanzlerin
wieder mit den länderchefs und chefinnen
beraten hat sie selbst schlägt vor sich
dabei auf persönliche kontakte bildung
und wirtschaft zu konzentrieren
kombiniert mit schnelltests klaus
brodbeck der druck auf die politik
steigt den shutter und zu locker und
schritt für schritt wieder zu öffnen
klar zu machen wie geht es weiter mit
corona trotz coruna darum geht es jetzt
zu verabreden ab welchen zahlen oder
welcher stabilität von zahlen oder
welche schutzmaßnahmen kann man sich was
zutrauen darum geht es diese perspektive
diskussion und nicht dinge von heute auf
morgen die über monate zu wahren von
heute auf morgen einfach öffnen
tatsächlich geht es durcheinander bayern
will ab montag wieder baumärkte öffnen
trotz stagnierender infektionszahlen
hamburg verschärft dann die maske
pflicht zu viele tummelten sich am
vergangenen wochenende zu dicht und in
flensburg gelten scharfe einschränkungen
schon jetzt wer jetzt wieder
hoffnungen weckt um sie sodann
bitterlich zu enttäuschen verspieltes
vertrauen der menschen es kann so nicht
weitergehen dass der gesamte mittelstand
dass einzelhändler gewerbetreibende de
facto vor die wand gefahren werden
flächendeckende tests gelten als
bedingung für mögliche lockerungen
heftig daher heute die kritik an
gesundheitsminister dessen test
strategie gestern platzte
es ist ein armutszeugnis für dann sparen
dass die schnelltests strategie wieder
verschoben wird die bundesregierung die
liefert immer wieder den beweis dafür
dass sie es nicht kann das corona
management ist eine einzige katastrophe
morgen muss der gesundheitsminister dem
parlament rede und antwort stehen
regierungsbefragung der druck steigt
schauen wir auf den stand beim impfen da
gibt es lob aber auch kritik an der
entscheidung von bund und ländern kita
beschäftigte und lehrkräfte von grund-
und förderschulen früher zu impfen
aktuell haben 4,1 prozent der
bevölkerung eine impfung erhalten
2,2 prozent auch die zweitimpfung und
die entwicklung wird sich beschleunigen
weil ab dieser woche große lieferungen
bevorstehen und astrazeneca impfstoff
liegt in größeren mengen auf lager jetzt
fordern niedergelassene ärzte und
ärztinnen ebenfalls früher geimpft zu
werden christoph westerwelle berichtet
thomas buck ist kinderarzt und damit
noch nicht dran beim impfen letztens hat
er einen ängstlichen patienten durch die
maske musste dem kleinen jungen gut
zureden und steckte sich dabei an
englische variante mittelschwerer
verlauf das genau fürchtet er jetzt im
großen stil wenn wir das im laufe der
fortsetzung der pandemie weitere
mitglieder der medizinischen betreuung
ausfallen
dann können wir diese betreuung nicht
mehr gerecht aufrechterhalten
wir werden ein ausfall des systems sehen
er fordert jetzt durchweg alle impfen
die mit patienten in kontakt kommen es
wäre der nächste eingriff in die
priorisierung leicester nachdem
polizisten werden bereits erzieher/innen
und grundschullehrer hochgestuft wieso
denn fragen die die mit der liste zuerst
einmal die am meisten gefährdeten leben
schützen wollten
zu diesem schritt habe ich jetzt wie
gesagt gemischte gefühle ich kann das
auf der einen seite verstehen auf der
anderen seite ist das ein abrücken
ich denke da muss man abwarten es geht
aber nicht mehr nur um ethik auch der
schlechte ruf des impfstoffs von
astrazeneca spielt hier eine rolle
völlig ungerechtfertigt sei der betonen
virologen doch fakt ist unter 65 jährige
die jetzt fürs impfen die hand heben
bekommen automatisch astrazeneca und das
heben nicht genug die hand wie zahlen
belegen bislang hat astrazeneca gut 1,4
millionen dosen nach deutschland
geliefert aber nur knapp 212.000 davon
wurden verimpft also etwa ein siebtel
zum vergleich von den gut 5,7 millionen
gelieferten biontech dosen sind 3,1
millionen verimpft mehr als die hälfte
die astrazeneca reserven managt nun
jedes bundesland etwas anders wäre etwa
der hausarzt thomas buck hesse und nicht
hannoveraner er könnte vielleicht schon
kommendes wochenende geimpft werden
trotz offizieller beschwerden aus der eu
verlängert deutschland die
grenzkontrollen an den übergängen zu
tschechien und tirol bis zum dritten
märz die betroffenen länder gelten in
deutschland seit mitte februar als
sogenannte virusvarianten gebiete die
einreise ist bis auf wenige auf
ausnahmen verboten
die eu kommission bezeichnete die
restriktion als unverhältnismässig
betonte aber man stehe mit deutschland
in kontakt und hoffe in den nächsten
tagen auf eine einigung in die usa dort
hat eine ganze nation der korona toten
gedacht und das sind jetzt mehr als
500.000 menschen präsident biden sagt
dass corinna bisher mehr amerikanische
opfer gefordert hat als der erste und
der zweite weltkrieg und
der vietnamkrieg zusammen biden spricht
von einer herzzerreißenden zahl hunderte
kerzen am weißen haus erinnern an die
opfer und an ihre familien
ines trams 500.000 corona tote in den
usa das präsidentenpaar verbeugt sich
vor den opfern schweigeminute im weißen
haus
joe biden will die pandemie bekämpfen
aber er will auch gedenken ohne
erinnerung keine heilung sagt er
wir müssen uns dagegen wehren taub für
das leid zu werden diese leben als eine
statistik zu sehen als einen unscharfen
fleck als etwas in den nachrichten wir
müssen die touren ehren ein beispiel von
500.000 familie es - sein kalifornien
nancys mann antonio starb nach seinem
kampf mit dem virus als krankenpfleger
hatte sich der 36-jährige familienvater
infiziert als er im krankenhaus war habe
ich nie daran gezweifelt dass er es
schaffen würde
ich vertraute so sehr auf ihn und auf
meinen glauben inzwischen sinken die
infektions und sterberaten in den usa
vor allem wegen der impfkampagne die joe
biden vorantreibt soldaten helfen bei
der organisation
geimpft wird in großen stadien kleinen
apotheken bis juli soll für alle 328
millionen amerikaner eine impfung
möglich sein
wir können aber noch nicht von sieg
sprechen wir haben die impfungen die ein
licht am ende des tunnels darstellen
aber wir wissen auch es gibt da noch die
neuen varianten
amerika trauert um eine halbe million
opfer für die nächsten fünf tage ließ
präsident biden die flaggen auf halbmast
setzen
zurück nach deutschland wohnraum ist
hier knapp vor allem bezahlbarer deshalb
hatte die bundesregierung 2018 eine
initiative gestartet
heute zog sie zwischenbilanz das ziel
war in dieser legislaturperiode 1,5
millionen neue wohnungen fertig zu
stellen darunter auch viele sozial wo
diese zahl wird wohl verfehlt und das
obwohl immer mehr gebaut wird
laut der förderbank kfw könnten es in
diesem jahr über 300.000 wohnungen
werden so viele wie seit 20 jahren nicht
mehr
doch das reicht nicht romanesco war
dachgeschossausbau in berlin steglitz
die charlottenburger baugenossenschaft
sieht sich bezahlbare wohnen
verpflichtet knapp fünf euro 50 kalt die
durchschnittsmiete doch die neuen
dachwohnungen werden doppelt so viel
kosten bauen bleibe zu teuer
die förderprogramme kommen hier nicht an
gerade für dachgeschoss nicht
grundstücke stehen nicht zur verfügung
das heißt wir spüren eigentlich nichts
im september 2018 verkündeten bund
länder und kommunen ein ganzes bündel an
maßnahmen darunter das baukindergeld zur
eigenheimförderung milliarden zuschüsse
vom bund für den sozialen wohnungsbau
bauland zu vergünstigten konditionen
oder einheitlichere bauordnungen durch
die länder
virtuell fällt die bundesregierung heute
eine positive zwischenbilanz am ende
dessen was gebraucht wird sei man aber
noch nicht
diese aufgabe eine permanente bleibt
dass wir da nicht am ende sind sondern
mittendrin und dass das auch ein großes
thema in der legislaturperiode wird das
ist glaube ich klar
kritische töne dagegen auch von
mieterseite legen weiter zu hoher preise
wird ein bundesweiter mieten stopp
gefordert
das heißt die nächsten sechs jahre gar
keine mieterhöhungen in der zeit kann
ordentlich gebaut werden
und wenn dann der wohnungsmarkt wieder
einigermaßen ausgeglichen ist dann kann
man mit diesem instrument auch wieder
aufhört für die charlottenburger
genossenschaft die forderung nicht zu
ende gedacht in berlin gilt einmieten
deckel jetzt fehlten einnahmen weshalb
man neubaupläne vorerst auf eis lege
bezahlbares wohnen bleibt ein
schwieriges thema auch nach zweieinhalb
jahren wohnraum offensive anderes
wichtiges thema heute die bundeswehr
eva högl die wehrbeauftragte des
bundestags hat ihren ersten
jahresbericht vorgelegt und berichtet
von vielen problemen in der truppe
besorgt ist sie wegen der steigenden
zahl neuer verdachtsfälle von
rechtsextremismus
und fordert mehr politische bildung
positiv hob die wehrbeauftragte die
arbeit der bundeswehr in der korona
pandemie hervor frank buchwald berichtet
sie helfen seit monaten überall in
deutschland sanitäts soldatinnen der
bundeswehr in einem impfzentrum berlin
amtshilfe in der pandemie viele menschen
sind froh darüber auch die neue
wehrbeauftragte des bundestages
wir können alle sehr stolz und dankbar
sein dass soldatinnen und soldaten so
tatkräftig unterstützt haben
und ehrlich gesagt die truppe hat auch
gezeigt was sie kann
das habe ich mir an vielen stellen
angeguckt dass es beeindruckend hügel
schlägt für diesen einsatz eine
besondere auszeichnung vor das
eigentliche training der truppe aber
leidet unter der pandemie von der
gewerkschaft der soldaten deshalb auch
kritische worte wir müssen ausbilden und
üben für landes- und bündnisverteidigung
für unsere einsätze in denen wir stehen
und gleichzeitig ist es ja auch so dass
diese übungen die ausbildung auch
eingeschränkt sind durch hygiene und
schutzmaßnahmen bei den spezialkräften
die durch munition schwund und
fragwürdige rituale ins gerede gekommen
waren
verlangt die wehrbeauftragte schnelle
aufklärung ebenso bei extremismus
vorwürfe
die große mehrheit der soldaten stehe
jedenfalls fest zur demokratie und
grundgesetz
deswegen kommt es mir so sehr darauf an
das wirklich auch schonungslos
aufzuklären dass es im übrigen auch
wichtig für den rest der bundeswehr die
mit extremismus nichts am hut haben
damit die soldatinnen und soldaten dann
auch aus der truppe entfernt werden
extremismus hat in der bundeswehr nichts
zu suchen
die meisten soldaten jedoch beschweren
sich bei hügel über schlechte ausrüstung
mangelhaftes gerät und zu viel
bürokratie so die seit vielen jahren
schon die katholischen bischöfe in
deutschland stehen unter druck
ihr digitales frühjahrstreffen ist zur
krisensitzung geworden
im zentrum des sturms steht der kölner
kardinal woelki sein handeln in der
missbrauchsdebatte können viele nicht
nachvollziehen
immer mehr katholiken kehren der kirche
den rücken
andere fordern grundlegende
veränderungen andrea budde berichtet
sexueller missbrauch
vertuschungsvorwürfe teils missratener
aufarbeitung die kirche ist in verruf
geraten vor allem in köln was da
passiert und wie die aufarbeitung der
katholischen kirche ist das finde ich
hier gar nicht ich finde das nimmt jetzt
ausmaße an die
die kann man einfach nicht mehr
akzeptieren
ihm gilt die kritik kardinal rainer
maria woelki
seit monaten hält er ein fertiges
gutachten über den umgang der bistums
spitze mit missbrauchsfällen unter
verschluss lässt mit dem hinweis auf
methodische mängel eine zweite studie
erstellen
ein verhalten das einen sturm auf online
termine für den kirchenaustritt in köln
auslöste vor wenigen tagen brach die
website zusammen die bischöfe haben sich
das thema missbrauch heute zum auftakt
auf die fahnen geschrieben wir müssen
wirklich aufklärung und aufarbeitung
betreiben sowie es bistümer vorbildlich
tun
ich sage aachen ich nenne auch mein
eigenes bistum limburg und köln
ich spreche dem kardinal nicht ab dass
er diesen willen hat und er wird sich
daran messen lassen
für eine maßregelung wirklich hat die
bischofskonferenz allerdings keine
kompetenzen die katholische kirche
braucht eine verfassungsreform sie muss
weg von dieser absolutistischen
monarchie hin zu demokratischen
strukturen in denen macht kontrolliert
wird und gewaltenteilung herrscht eine
neuerung gab es schon heute eine frau
wurde generalsekretär in der deutschen
bischofskonferenz zum aller ersten mal
letztes jahr war an dieser stelle noch
die frage kann eine frau ein solches amt
hier
wir haben jetzt wissen wir es geht
ein anfang ist gemacht
ein interessantes gespräch gleich um
halb acht comedian carolin kebekus und
eine vertreterin von maria 2.0 bei zdf
heute live sie können ihre fragen
stellen
das ganze in unserer heute app wie
youtube und facebook nach malta der
justiz krimi um die getötete
journalistin daphne caro anna galizia
hat eine überraschende wendung genommen
einer von drei männern die wegen mordes
an der bloggerin vor gericht stehen hat
sich schuldig bekannt
er wurde zu 15 jahren gefängnis
verurteilt galizia war 2017 in ihrem
auto in die luft gesprengt worden
sie hatte über korruption in politik und
wirtschaft recherchiert in den zoos
drängen sich die menschen vor ihren
gehegen in freiheit wird es sie
vielleicht bald gar nicht mehr geben
orang utans sie leben in den
dschungelgebieten indonesiens die
meisten auf der insel borneo gut 100000
schätzt man doch ihr lebensraum wird
immer kleiner auch wilderer und
schmuggler haben es auf eurem utans
abgesehen gerettete tiere werden
möglichst wieder ausgebildet über eine
solche aktion berichtet nahm odenthal -
großer tag beginnt betäubt denn was
folgt kann man mit einem orang-utan im
wachen zustand kaum machen
januar wird durchgecheckt auf herz und
nieren und auf corvette die pandemie
kann wohl auch orang-utans erwischen sie
sind den menschen nah verwandt und noah
muss kerngesund sein für dieses
abenteuer aus dem auffanglager geht es
zurück in die wildnis
er kam mit gut vier jahren zu uns ins
lager sie wurde vorher als attraktion in
einem vergnügungspark gehalten die
mussten sie erst wieder ein wildes leben
gewöhnen nach 13 jahren ist sie jetzt zu
weit
futter finden gefahren erkennen all das
haben sie im lager trainiert rüstzeug
für den dschungel da unten
januar zählt zu den letzten ihrer art
die orang utans kämpfen ums überleben
das gelingt nur in geschützten wäldern
den letzten rückzugsräumen distanz zum
menschen tut gut
wir fliegen sie mit dem helikopter aus
während der pandemie ist das am
sichersten unser ziel ist eine hügelige
gegend die autofahrer drei tage wir
würden durch dörfer fahren wo menschen
leben das erhöht das risiko einer kuwait
ansteckung zehn tiere werden heute in
die freiheit entlassen
das erste schritte sind fast zögerlich
aber die tierschützer wissen wenn sie
erstmal in den wäldern verschwindet hat
sie gute chancen
garantien gibt es keine das leben da
draußen ist wild und frei und nun zur
fußball-champions-league da trifft
morgen abend gladbach auf manchester
city nicht und das wird ganz schön
schwer für die borussia die schwäche ja
zurzeit in der bundesliga mancity
dagegen souveräne englische
tabellenführer 18 pflichtspielsiege in
folge
gladbachs noch-trainer marco rose
fordert von seinem team vertrauen mut
und leidenschaft alle augen in
mönchengladbach derzeit auf ihn
gerichtet trainer marco rose stürmische
tage am niederrhein das team beim
abschlusstraining von corona bedingten
tritt nach budapest gegen city wollen
sie sich neues selbstvertrauen holen es
wird über gutes verteidigen vor allen
dingen gehen und dann aber und das ist
ein ganz wichtiger punkt vor allen
dingen auch über übermut ich fußball
spielen weil wenn mancity sicher eins
nicht mag dann wenn sie wenn sie den
ball nicht haben mutig fußball spielen
und besser verteidigen als am wochenende
in der liga gegen mainz mönchengladbach
außenseiter beim heimspiel in budapest
gegen guardiola aus manchester wollen
sie trotzdem hoch hinaus zur nordischen
ski-wm oberstdorf ist ab morgen zum
dritten mal austragungsort skisprung
langlauf und nordische kombination alle
wettbewerbe ohne publikum ja und bei
frühlingshaften temperaturen für die
veranstalter eine enorme herausforderung
bei temperaturen von bis zu 15 grad in
oberstdorf werden die langlauf rennen
früher am morgen als geplant beginnen
damit bessere bedingungen in der loipe
herrschen dass eine weitere
herausforderung bei dieser wm ohne
zuschauer an der inklusive der 800
athleten gut 5000 menschen beteiligt
sind ein wagnis zu kurz
jeder teilnehmer egal ob jetzt
medienschaffender sportler oder auch die
volontäre sind in einer blase in einem
engen kreis und werden unermüdlich
getestet sportlich sind die deutschen
hoffnungen beim skispringen und vor
allem bei der nordischen kombination
angesiedelt doch die konkurrenz ist groß
und das macht ja die kommenden 12 tage
so spannend ich habe auch noch was
brandes es gibt neues vom mars nie
dagewesenes nie gehörtes die
us-raumfahrtbehörde präsentiert
spektakuläre bilder von der landung
ihres rovers viren die eigentliche
sensation aber die mikrofone nehmen auf
dem mars geräusche auf und die klingen
wie eine windböe offenbar eine steife
brise da oben solche tonaufnahmen sagt
die nasa habe es noch nie gegeben
der ungewöhnlichen milde februar setzt
sich auch morgen fort mehr dazu gleich
von ost-berlin so viel von uns wird im
moment schön dass sie dabei waren
mehr gibt es dann um drei viertel 10 min
im heute journal mit marietta slomka und
morgen begrüßt sie hier an dieser stelle
christian sievers wir wünschen ihnen
noch einen entspannten dienstagabend bis
dann
[Musik]
einen schönen abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter wir haben es
derzeit mit einer sehr milden witterung
ungewöhnlich milden witterung zu tun
und so sind in den letzten tagen in
einigen stationen die rekorde durchaus
gepurzelt das war heute der fall und
morgen ebenfalls denn wir haben es mit
einer südwestlichen strömung immer noch
zu tun hier kommt die warme luft zu uns
dieses hoch her dass blockiert den weg
der tiefs und so können sie nicht
vorwärts kommt
dafür wird die warme luft angesaugt und
mit dabei auch saharastaub das haben sie
vielleicht mitbekommen der himmel war
recht trüb heute schauen wir die nacht
da gibt es nach süden in wenige worte
dafür nebel richtung main und donau im
norden sind einige harmlose wolken
unterwegs und das bei temperaturen bis
minus 2 grad im südosten deutschlands
viel leichter frost und zwölf grad mild
im westen deutschlands morgen nach
nebelauflösung viel sonnenschein
ansonsten an der donau kann es durchaus
üblich bleiben im norden wieder harmlose
wolken unterwegs bei höchsten
temperaturen bis 21 grad im südwesten
oder teilweise im osten sie sehen hier
häufig temperaturen um die 20 grad marke
unter am donnerstag noch mal viel
sonnenschein bei elf bis 20 grad und ab
freitag von norden her kühler und etwas
regen dabei einen schönen abend